what do you think of when you hear the
word vacation perhaps you imagine Lying
by a beach watching the sunset over the
clear blue water feeling the sand
between your toes a tropical drink in
your hand perhaps you see yourself in a
cozy log cabin in the woods snow gently
falling outside a roaring fire warming
your feet while you catch up on your
reading or maybe you think of a
luxurious Spa seaweed wraps natural hot
springs and cucumber slices on your eyes
but what about those of us who are sick
of the usual getaways on offer who want
to take a trip that not only shakes up
their routine but their sense of reality
as they once knew it here at Marshall
Carter and dark we strive to provide
vacation experiences for the more
Discerning traveler the more um shall we
say adventurous someone who's had enough
of those white sand beaches in the
Caribbean who's sick of Villas in the
south of France and wants to invest
their hard-earned money in a destination
that is completely and utterly unique
we've curated a selection of potential
vacation destinations to choose from for
just this sort of customer someone with
an adventurous spirit and money to burn
from The mind-bendingly Surreal to the
downright dangerous we promise that a
trip to one of our Prestige vacation
spots will help you make memories you
won't soon forget no matter how hard you
try most of our usual clientele wouldn't
dream of Furnishing their home with
items from an Ikea but don't let that
stop you from considering the first
destination in our catalog
scp-3008 also known as the infinite Ikea
is less of a retail store and more of an
all-inclusive experience it looks like
an ordinary IKEA from the outside but
inside well that's a different story
altogether once you've passed through
the main entrance to the building the
possibilities are literally endless as
the interior extends to an infinite size
defying all-known mods of physics you'll
find a variety of accommodations from
any furniture piece you can think of to
a wide array of Scandinavian culinary
Delights just watch out for the faceless
entities and employ uniforms and don't
let them catch you after dark here's
what Mary 45 from Pennsylvania had to
say about her stay in the infinite Ikea
please God someone get me out of here
they took my husband and I'm getting so
sick of Meatballs
are you something of a city slicker
looking for a country mouse experience
trying to get away from all the hustle
and bustle and just kick back and relax
but also want to avoid going to the same
idyllic English Villages that all your
friends at the Country Club have already
tried look no further than temby a
Charming little hamlet in Oxfordshire
England with its own specialized local
curse you won't find this phenomenon
anywhere else making for a truly
exclusive experience every 12 years an
invisible entity known as The Crooked
Man spends 70 days targeting random
individuals in the town's limits
corrupting the shape of their house
tormenting them with Supernatural
activity and finally twisting and
breaking their bones stretching their
limbs out beyond recognition but don't
worry as a new visitor to the town it's
unlikely you'll be picked and even if
you are who doesn't like coming home
from a trip with a fresh new look here's
what gym 32 from New York City thought
about its time in tenby you can't
imagine the things I've heard the things
I've seen have you ever seen a man whose
legs bent in a dozen different
directions so stretched out and deformed
he can't even stand up anymore I have
the worst part was when the screaming
stopped when he got used to the feeling
of stretching and cracking bones
snapping over and over and over again
until it was something else I hear that
sound at night just before I fall asleep
I see him when I close my eyes I wish it
had taken me too but maybe that isn't
quite what you have in mind maybe you're
looking for a more permanent vacation
you've had quite enough of the
annoyances of everyday life of your
neighbor's dog that won't stop barking
at all hours of the night of the
stranger standing too close to you in
the line at Starbucks and breathing down
your neck you just want to leave it all
behind for good and finally get some
peace and quiet if this sounds like you
then why not check out
scp-2935 this space-time anomaly tucked
away inside of a limestone k beneath a
cemetery near Joppa Indiana contains the
gateway to a world identical to our own
with one exception every single life
form there is dead from the birds and
the bees to the flowers and the trees to
that bartender that never makes your
Martini the way you like it no matter
how many times you explain it to him
they're all gone but keep in mind what
happens in
scp-2935 stays in
scp-2935 by which I mean once you're
there you can't come back otherwise
death Will Follow You into our world and
we can't have that now can we I'd
provide you with a testimony from a
satisfied customer who stayed in
scp-2935 but every time I try to get
Eliza 27 from Los Angeles on the phone
it's just static so I guess you'll have
to take my word for it maybe you're not
just looking for a vacation to help you
get away from it all perhaps you're
looking for a chance to self-reflect
well there is no better place for that
than
scp-1919 or the hotel of duplicates it's
an early 20th century hotel and
converted Mansion located at an
undisclosed location address will be
provided to you upon booking on the
outside it's in mostly pristine
condition but looks can be deceiving the
inside is dilapidated and rotten covered
in water damage when you enter the hotel
doppelgangers of you will manifest
throughout the building looking exactly
like you with a few noticeable
differences maybe they'll be missing
their eyes or have unnaturally long arms
or large Jaws whatever the case may be
all of these mirror images will become
aggressive attempting to destroy you by
any means necessary you can either
succumb to the attacks of your infinite
doubles or somehow escape with your life
talk about a way to get the blood
pumping and by coming face to face with
yourself and your own flaws you'll be
able to leave the experience with a new
lease on life if you survive that is
Roberto 55 from Indianapolis had a great
time at the hotel of duplicates just
listen to his testimony no mirrors
please cover the mirrors I can't look at
it I can't look at my face there were so
many of them so much blood up next is
scp-3001 or the red reality after so
much time trapped in there Dr Scranton
needs some company just kidding of
course we may be ruled by the almighty
dollar but we're not monsters we'd never
subducted paying customer to the horrors
of the red reality speaking of red
places though Kickback poolside with
scp-354 the red pool you probably will
want to swap out your swimsuit for a
down coat because it gets pretty cold up
in the wilderness of Northern Canada but
hey a pool is a pool this pool is filled
not with chlorinated water but a thick
red liquid similar to human blood don't
worry though it's not actually blood
well that would be ridiculous it's just
a mysterious liquid of an unknown origin
filling a pool that has no discernible
bottom every so often creatures will
emerge from the pool and attempt to
attack you and anything else they see
who needs a trip to the zoo when the
animals can come to you am I right you
may encounter giant bats a levitating
black sphere that emits directed beams
of radiation an unknown Abomination
covered in tentacles or something else
you can't even imagine so pour a drink
kick off your shoes and maybe keep your
favorite weapon at the ready as you
Lounge by the side of this picturesque
red pool Brandy 24 from Chicago had a
fantastic time at the red pool this is
mochi she's my cloud cat yeah Cat made
out of water vapor she came out of the
pool and I gave her some tuna sashimi
and now she's my best friend don't get
too close to her though she's not into
most humans she'll take your skin right
off
London Town have you ever wanted to go
to London but find it just a bit too
mainstream well what if there was a
place you could visit that's just like
London but not quite well I've got some
great news for you person with
incredibly specific tastes
scp-1678 or unlund is a full-scale
mirror image of London located one
kilometer beneath the city itself it's a
truly underground spot if you're a fan
of the Vintage look then that's even
better unlondon is modeled after the
city as it appeared in the Victorian era
with gas lighting on the streets instead
of electric and architecture reflecting
that time period on London was
constructed for human habitation after
an apocalyptic scenario so make yourself
comfortable take a nap in a
military-grade bunk bed wander around
the Natural History Museum's fall of Man
exhibit and Savor a nice bowl of Dr
Goody's Wonder food just be on the
lookout for the Bobbies mechanized
corpses fashioned into makeshift police
officers they don't take kindly to
trespassers but don't take my word for
it listen to Chuck 44 from Boston and
London was wonderful I love consuming
the nutrients found in Dr Goody's
wonderfood provides me with everything
my body needs I'm not frightened of the
Bobbies anymore I'm a good citizen I do
not fear the eyes in the sky and I do
not pity the wretches they pay the price
for their betrayals and I will pay it
the rest of their days the trip was
worth the scurvy sometimes you want to
get out of civilization and spend some
time reconnecting with nature getting
back to your roots if you want to go to
a place where nobody knows your name and
nobody should ever find out what it is
then may I recommend
scp-4000 I can't tell you too many
details about it you'll just have to see
its unique charms for yourself but it's
a forest that can be entered if you
complete the proper ritual emerge from a
well and walk down a path to your
destination there are a few strict rules
you'll need to follow during your stay
amongst the anomalous creatures that
dwell there don't call Anything by a
consistent name don't answer to a
consistent name always accept gifts but
do not consume them and finally if a
ghost tells you it isn't a creature obey
it don't let all the rules scare you
though the beings in this Enchanted
Forest make for some really good
neighbors just ask Barb
say my name you do it'll take it and
once my name is gone the rest of me
follows don't go
and dance with them no matter how
sweetly they ask and don't eat what they
give you never ever eat it it's just
like the old poem says we must not look
at the goblin men we must not buy their
fruits who knows upon what soil they fed
their hungry thirsty roots I know I said
that these were all vacation spots but
have you ever considered finding a new
home instead somewhere where you could
really put down roots and build a
community the people of scp-599 are
always looking for new neighbors after
all it's a small City located in an
undisclosed location earning it the
nickname Uncharted City don't be
dissuaded by the fact that everyone
living in the town matches the
description of someone who went missing
in a different inferior town this is a
perfectly nice place to live and once
you visit you'll never want to leave
just ask Mario 65 from Virginia you
should really think about purchasing a
house here I had such a lovely place to
raise a family just come and stay the
night you'll see this place was made for
you picture this if you will you're
staying the night in a luxurious
Victorian Mansion and it's a dark and
stormy night a clap of Thunder shakes
you from your Slumber and a flash of
lightning illuminates the bedroom where
you sleep your heart leaps into your
throat as you think you can see someone
standing at the foot of your bed you
want a candle to check but no it's just
a chair with a coat slung over the back
you're alone just you the enormous empty
house and the sound of rain
pitter-pattering against the window you
can't relax though can't get your mind
to slip back into the Blissful Escape of
sleep you feel as if the walls are
closing in on you as if the room is
getting smaller and smaller enveloping
you in darkness you take your candle and
use it to light the way as you slowly
open the door to the bedroom with an
eerie Creek then you step out into the
Hall what was that sound that soft sign
the padding of footsteps coming from
over there you turn shining the
flickering light of flame in the
direction of the noise and see the
figure of a woman in a long flowing
dress she's beautiful or she would be if
she looked alive instead she's pale
translucent her wide dark eyes staring
into your very soul you can smell the
scent of rotting your flowers the salt
and iron of tears and blood slowly she
begins to drift toward you not walk but
float as if her feet never touch the
ground you open your mouth to scream but
no sound comes out she reaches her
ghostly fingers out to brush her cheek
and everything goes black doesn't that
sound like a one-of-a-kind experience
don't be scared that was no malicious
Spirit it was just the lady of the house
Clara rossyth may not be the best
hostess but her home is lovely a stately
Mansion located in dark peat in
Derbyshire England sure it's a little
haunted but hey all the best historical
houses are Daphne 42 from London had
this to say about her stay there so cold
cold check the children please you have
to check the children settle down Daphne
go back to bed ah now where was I now
maybe you don't want to be confined to
the space within the walls of a haunted
house or any house for that matter so
how about we get back to Nature with a
nice simple Lakeside camping trip just
set up your tent at least 50 meters away
from the water and take in the crisp
fresh air and wonderful view feel the
breeze rolling in off the lake and oh
what's that do you see something
floating in the water it's all right
it's just
scp-2316 if you look for a while it
might start to look familiar right Chris
from Iowa I recognize them the bodies in
the water I know them my friend I'm so
sorry I have to go I have to go to them
all right buddy you do that anyway if
you do decide to visit scp-2316 try and
remember you do not recognize the bodies
in the water and maybe don't take a dip
in that particular Lake you've heard
about Christmas in December and even
Christmas in July but how would you like
to visit a place where it's Christmas
all year round and the holiday fun never
stops if that sounds like heaven on
Earth to you then you'll be a perfect
fit for scp-784 Christmas cheer this
quaint little neighborhood in Texas
doesn't have much to offer in terms of
sites with only 24 houses and two
apartment buildings but the atmosphere
more than makes up for it no matter what
time of year you visit the town will
always be covered in a layer of freshly
fallen snow and every building is
wrapped in Christmas lights at a density
of 15 lights per square meter and if you
thought the decor was Charming wait
until you meet the residents every
person in scp-784 is dressed in their
holiday best usually in novelty
Christmas sweaters emblazoned with a
smiling reindeer Santa Claus glittering
ornaments and twinkling lights and
really just about anything that screams
Christmas during the day the townspeople
decorate their houses and exchange
presents as well as putting on Christmas
pageants and dances when night falls
they will share eggnog sing Christmas
carols and decorate any foreign objects
that might have made their way into the
town's vicinity just make sure that you
keep your Christmas spirit at its best
and brightest while you're visiting or
you might find yourself tied up with
string lights and dragged into the
nearest house for a bit of Yuletide
reprogramming whether you're looking for
a place to spend Christmas or just
trying to inject a bit of extra
festivity into your everyday life this
is the perfect place for your ho ho ho
holiday unfortunately none of our
clients who've chosen this destination
will stop singing carols long enough to
provide testimony but just take that as
a sign that their time in this Christmas
Village was truly life-changing do you
consider yourself something of a
bookworm when your friends are going out
to private clubs enjoying gourmet
dinners or headed on early morning hikes
on the beach do you prefer to stay in
and crack open your favorite novel then
perhaps you'd like a visit to the best
library in any known universe that's
right a book Lover's fantasy The
Wanderers library is an interdimensional
library that acts as the embodiment of
all knowledge its ever expanding
collection of literature includes every
book ever written and some that haven't
even been written yet in your native
timeline wander the endless stacks of
books take in the peaceful environment
and study up on any subject your heart
desires and if you're not prepared to
completely unplug there's also Wi-Fi
Professor Lisa Graham thoroughly enjoyed
her stay in The Wanderers Library I know
a little bit about everything now I've
looked into the past the present the
future the greatest Minds in the
Multiverse at my fingertips how am I
supposed to go back to my nine to five
job after that now we have covered quite
a few places under the jurisdiction of
the SCP Foundation the SCP Foundation
site 19 is the perfect getaway for a
real Foundation Enthusiast someone who's
a massive fan of the work they do and
excited to see all of their favorite
anomalies and scientists meet the famous
Dr Jack Bright just don't touch the
amulet say hello to Dr gears before he
shoes you away so he can focus on his
work and do you like anomalies well
they've got them in Spades here
scp-035 the possessive mask glowers out
from its protective glass case
scp-096 huddles in the corner of its
containment cell hiding its face no
peeking maybe you'll get to see scp-049
performing one of his trademark
experiments though if you're feeling
under the weather you might not want to
let him see you maybe you want to sneak
a look at SCP-173 and see if you can
catch it snapping any d-class necks feel
something nudging your foot it's just
the friendly instances of scp-131 here
to check things out and make sure you're
having a fantastic time if you're tired
get some rest in the employee's sleeping
quarters hungry and grab a bite of the
canteen there's just so much to do here
at Foundation site 19. hey you're not
authorized to be in here just giving it
to her gentlemen I'll be finished in a
moment so I'm gonna have to ask you to
leave if you don't comply I'll have to
use Force looks like that's my cue all
all payments can be made out to Marshall
Carter and dark think of us when you
book your next vacation and remember
absolutely no refunds under any
circumstances now go and check out
scp-2521 and info Hazard scps explained
and scp-002 the living room and the most
terrifying SCP rooms for more malevolent
SCP rundowns